here but the connection you see I mean
the algorithm in some sense beats a
lower bond that was proven via for
analytic techniques and let me describe
it exactly you know what is the lower
one into the upper bound so first of all
I mentioned my coffers so this is work
gent with rindi Quinn grin and nearly
our adesh time ok so we problem i'm
talking about is nearest neighbor search
which is i hope many of you have seen it
before it's a basic geometric question
we think about eating high dimensional
spaces so we have a set of four HD the
purpose is to build a data structure on
it so that given a new point query q we
can very quickly report the closest
point p okay and the problem just a
quick slide on motivation i know this
might be the wrong choir for this but
you know just bear with me so the newest
in research appears especially the high
dimensional version appears in practice
for because the points usually model
some kind of objects for example images
right images you know kind of beat for
example these binary vectors right and
the distance for example Hamming
distance mode of some kind of
dissimilarity between these images right
and this is you know under simple search
will give you this k nearest neighbor
rule which is like one of the basic
classifiers in machine learning and
because of that it has a lot of
applications for music recognition by
informatics and what so very fundamental
problem for a dimensional geometry and
this distance just to say that you know
the points can come from different
spaces the distances can be different so
i'll talk here about hanging in
euclidean but this could be Lydia this
could be Eddie distance from over
distance and then our options so why is
this important in the in geometry we
could also because this seems to be a
very fundamental like a fundamental
primitive that appears in many other
problems so for example if you want to
solve the closest pair problem you can
you can solve it your gear new business
number search or for example for some
verses of clustering and so forth ok so
this is the motivation for the problem
so getting to the algorithms
on so this is very aware there is this
notion of course of dimensionality
things become very hard with higher
dimension so if you want to construct an
algorithm then there are essentially the
exact problem there are two three
extremes one is to do you know
essentially full indexing prepare for
possible queries but then your space
will be exponential in D in particular
antipoverty or the other option is not
to do anything be lazy and in this
situation you know there is no pre
processing space will be linear but the
query time will be linear as well right
and in general you know we'd like to
combine these two basically linear space
and create a time which would be you
know the D think of dimension is log n
the sea right so on putlocker in aquaria
time ok so because of because of
hardness of approximate of exact there
is no notion of approximate nearest
neighbor search and let me just define
it quickly what it is even before i go
to approximate let me define a
fresh-caught version of nearest neighbor
where I don't ask the closest point but
I asked given a threshold in advance
threshold are think of this like scale
for example I want any point of in
distance R so pictorially rather than
giving the closest point I might give I
bro these two points this is a fine
answer and now approximate salute in
Japan is approximate is the following
promised problem let's say I guarantee
but there is nothing in this analyst
which is between R and C are and I said
that if there is something inside here
report me any point within this ser ok
so put differently like if there is
nothing in this yellow area then it like
guarantee that there is nothing and then
you have to report the near neighbor ok
and you know the problem with the
randomized so we'll return a point P
with ninety percent probability okay ah
so you know his approximate alders there
has been a number of Forex since you
know the decades now so let me talk
about on particular direction for four
algorithms disease called locality
sensitive hashing and think about local
excessive hashing as a run
myspace partitions okay maybe this would
be more familiar to you so what we build
here so how do we how do we do this kind
of algorithms we partition the space
using some hash function which maps for
example so this is for opinion space but
you can think about also having from RD
to some universe some some integer
universe such that for any two points
first of all new partition will have a
guarantee which is kind of has to part
and one part says something about close
points it means we've in distance R so
this is you know the distance over close
point to be in your neighbor you know
positive answer and far is everybody
else this is kind of the false near
neighbor at the points we do not want to
report and what do we want from this
partitioning we want this partitioning
such that the probability with points
collide when we are close is high and
the probability that they collide when
the points are far is small so just make
sure how many people have seen what
Collison see flashing before ok cool so
if you're a number ok so I'll go quicker
than so this is how roughly it would
look like and how to construct so this
is a random hash function how to
construct such a data structure for a
nearest-neighbor data structure which is
partitioned you hash into a table and
when a query comes you go into the
bucket where you'd falls into and you
look for your points here and if this is
really like this you know how you say
one and small is zero then you know
we'll find exactly our near neighbor in
the bucket right so now probably know
that you know this is not really
possible to have you know such a big
contrast between high and small so
usually what is obtainable but you know
this probability is not so small this
probability small and you have a
particular gap of which you play and you
know just pictorially you have a hash
function which partitions the space such
that the probability of collision drops
somehow with the distance and you know
the better of the faster it drops the
battery you know we get all business in
a particular when so once we get
something but we sort we will not use
just one hash table because one hash
table we might not find in your neighbor
so we'll have to do several hash tables
basically pick several space partitions
and we hope it at least in
Swiss partition we find in your neighbor
and the number of vegetables is
specified by this parameter row so it is
n 2 power r 0 is sub sub unitary so less
than 1 and just to define how r 0 looks
like so let me define probabilities p1
and p2 so p1 is this probability but we
collide when the distances are it Wiz
probability that we collide when the
distance is here and Roy is such that
this inequality holds right so think of
this as you know we want to set P to
roughly to be 1 over N and then t1
becomes something like 1 over N to power
so this is how many times will repeat
okay so this is you know this is the
approach right i mean now i shall tell
you kind of you know we need to
construct these random hash functions
that achieve interesting cross right and
so this is what was proposed in there is
no Linda ignore any paper so i should
say that you know we can define actually
this function g as a concatenation of
primitive functions the notion of
rhodamine is exactly the same this
allows us to do some boosting and just
to do lsh you know just to give an
example so how to do such a random
partitioning hemming space well does
define coordinate cut right this is just
pick a random coordinate coordinate cut
this will give you space partitioning
right so formally this will be pika
random jai your hash function will be a
projection on coordinate j and you know
you can compute exactly this probability
so it decreases goes down the distance
between P and Q and you know you can
compute exactly the t is doing some
approximations you plug in the formulas
you get one ever seen okay so as long as
the approximation is bigger than one you
get you get sub linear query time okay
so this is roughly how it goes right and
so what do we know so let me kind of you
know have a table with kind of what
people you know what is known about this
and let me in kind of partition this by
l1 and l2 because the results as like a
different even burger directly related
because of the you know embeddings and
so the original paper approved
row equals to 1 over C and by the
standard dominica fault went well one
this also transfers to Euclidean space
as well so later work in later we showed
that in Euclidean space you can get
roughly 1 over C squared and and so this
is the case and in meanwhile people have
started thinking about lower bounds so
you know you have a space partition and
you can think about you know can we
prove a lower bound saying that you know
this is this is the best based partition
you can get an ending in deed the first
time motwani an hour and panigrahi
showed the throw has to be essentially
more than half / singh 0.5 i see at
least for high enough approximation so
this is the original think about and
later on O'Donnell vu and zoo showed
that row has to be at least one ever
seen so essentially showing that this is
tight okay and again just because you
know we can put hemming into l2 squared
okay so do the same holds for the same
holds for l2 squared there are also
results for so prob lower bounds so this
is by panigrahi tovar on dinner which
essentially show that if you want space
less than this and this is kind of a
trade offs then you need some super
constant number of memory lookups so
probes okay so you know if you know I
won't go with these into so probs Laura
bones but you know this is this is what
I want to point out but for liquids is
locally assistive hashing but with space
partitions for this definition of you
know take hash function partition the
space what is this contrast you know
this is pipe right this row say one over
C and here is one over C squared 1 over
C square is tight okay so you know lsha
spite and you know is is the only thing
left here to prove you know tight cell
probe lower bounds is at all apparently
know so this is our main result where we
show that we can actually get nearest
neighbor search in say Euclidean hanging
space with row which is seven eighths by
sea
at least for high enough see ok so these
I know the lower bound was one over C
right so this is improving by constantly
exponent and this is you know first
improvement over original vocalizes you
hashing for hemming space and actually
we obtained videos out there showing
near simple search in Euclidean space
where we get you know the the equivalent
basically rho is equal to 7 8 divided by
c square this was a high enough see and
this also improves upon our previous
paper with better to drink Nick okay so
these are the results and probably you
know the interesting part that you know
I should really explain here in the talk
is why is it possible to go around the
lower bound right so for that you know I
will so this is the algorithm that I
want to focus on this regime because
this will imply also a result here and
how does it go so let me let us look at
the real estate lower bounds roughly how
are we proved I mean so so the lower
bounds approved the hanging space
because this is also implying the lower
bounds in the Euclidean space so we are
you know usually for your analytic and
let's say you know the original the
setting off and funny on our panigrahi
roughly you know so like sorry I mean I
won't show you the details but roughly
kind of what is the setting you know
what do you have to prove so you know
you pick any any distribution over hash
function so the space partitions so you
define p2 to be this probability of
collision of random pnq in the Hamming
space key one is probability of
collision between P and Q which is
essentially noised p right so we add the
right amount of noise so that the gap of
the distances exactly see and ok and we
you know some smart work you get raw is
at least half / seen okay so then the
question is okay you know okay can we
can we get better right and here's later
on over to show that yes we can get
tight roll and essentially this
uh you know these are modifications in
this setting the proof is different I
should say you know there is much more
work but but this is the difference so
basically rather than looking at the
distance between random pair versus you
know P and Q which are correlated that's
something we we we correlate B&Q in the
above setting and you know this is
correlation say of sorry noise epsilon i
Dessay know is epsilon by sea okay and
it is setting you can get raw is at
least one ever seen okay so so the
question is okay so you know why isn't
this the not a nearest neighbor search
lower bound so this is not an arrestable
search level because these this kind of
distribution doesn't lead to a
distribute to a good distribution on we
have endpoints so they have n points
basically what do we need to do we need
to pick a point query q and then we need
to take a lot of false in your neighbors
many points which are far away but they
all need to be correlated with key
because this is a distribution right so
now it's not now but you have a lot of
points that are correlated with q veas
means there is a small bowl that
contains all of them and you know if you
think about it when the near neighbor
has to be roughly close to the center of
that ball so kind of if you look at the
data at the beginning even before the
query comes you already see some
structure of the data so this structure
can be exploited so this is a message
right and you know you can dance like
well can we prove row equals to one
overseeing the distance regime Hough vs
1 half x see you know where this problem
doesn't appear so the answer is no so
actually this regime even the original
kind of coordinate cut will give you a
row which is roughly this of this form
0.72 by C so you cannot prove such a
lower bound and in fact even though this
was not done for nearest neighbor but
for a you know essentially close a
related problem which is your flying
problem the closest pair problem where
the times are something like n to power
1 plus row so in 2010 beginner showed
this kind of lower bound which kind of
suggested off that looks like a half by
C so again think of cs being
sufficiently large so actually at least
so and this is for random data
okay so random data and maybe it's a bit
is that a lot of random data and maybe
one peer is correlated so you know so
that we have the gap of a distance ok so
this later was improved by Greg valiant
for this case to truly subkey the
Cobblers is truly some quadratic
algorithm action using opera methods
okay so you know so this is services
intuition and afraid why why the lower
bound is not inserted a lower bound for
nearest neighbor search okay so how do
we you know how so how does the
operation proceeds so i'll give you a
high-level overview of the algorithm so
the idea is to do data dependent
locality sensitive hashing so think
about this so originally what we did say
you know random coordinate cut or for
euclidean space you do this ball carving
procedure if you know what I'm talking
about but the the space partitioning was
independent of the actual data so you
would argue only about pairs of points
so here the idea is to say that let look
at the data but the endpoints that we
have and let's do space partitions still
random series partitions but that we
depend on the data okay so so there are
two components kind of you know roughly
speaking one is to identify a particular
geometric configuration of point where
we really obtain raw which is less than
1 over C squared so it will be kind of
idea to be something like half divided
by C squared and then will be a
reduction from the general case to this
case ok and ok each of these steps will
at least the idea will be just one slide
okay so so assume we have we have the
following setting so all the points are
honest here okay this year doesn't show
up our own a sphere of radius he are
divided by root x Rotom so let me yeah
so this is this year so the radius is c
r by root 2 so CR think of is like c r
is the distance between you know far
pair-wise r by root 2 because if you
take two random points on site such high
dimensional sphere then the points will
be roughly a distance here
so essentially it kind of simulate this
random situation for hemming space where
one could get roll better than you know
what does the lower bound so in this
situation one can obtain raw which is
half divided by C square and you know
proof okay it is it's just a picture not
a proof i guess but this can be obtained
by you know what looks like cap carving
so pictorially you draw some random
lines that cut parts of the caps of this
year this defines this will be one
bucket you know you do it several times
this will be another bucket and the sore
throat so basically each new each new
line carves out you know the rubber part
that still remains right and basically
each of these parts you know will define
a bucket so this is somewhat similar to
ball carving that was originally done
for some rounding and bicarbonate when
you so done then we also used with the
changing for doing for painting despite
localizes hashing fake linear space so
in this setting at least it turns out
that role that you obtain is better you
obtain half divided by C square Oh in
interest of time I won't be able to
explain why but in general if afraid use
I mean this this kind of improvement
over the lower bound is possible even
when the radius is slightly more than
she are so if it is more by some a
thought I think of like 10 then you
still obtain something that is better
depends on a turret it degree to the
case of a turret I mean something has to
decay with something because we cannot
obtain one over better than 10 C squared
in general this is kind of this special
configuration where we can obtain better
oh and in general the idea is to
of the reduction is to apply a few
rounds of regular local insisted hashing
something like bull carving which and
then apply the spherical message so
intuitively what what happens is that so
we can apply this or you know data
independent partitioning but will
partition space a bit and we'll make the
heart points unlikely to collide so
basically it reduces to the case where
the points are more clustered so you
know if you set up the premise right
when these partitions with it into
buckets of diameter which is roughly
proportional to order CR so think of
this is at the CR then you find the
minimum closing ball in each bucket and
on each of these minimum closing ball
you apply this Sarah colocalizes fashion
ok so just pictorially I mean kind of to
describe the algorithm how it looks like
so we again will have essentially an to
power or hash tables each with a hash
function but his function will not be
just a concatenation of you know data
independent hash functions you know
however many there was needed now we'll
have a prefix will be you know some
participates partitioning which is data
independent and essentially kind of
construct some kind of structure or
exhibit some kind of structure from our
data and after that after we can reduce
the data to some more mo structure we
apply this spherical osage which gives
us better exponent so in general this
ball carving will look like you know
balls that are just carved out of the
space they have something like this this
is this is this part this data
independent part and then you look in
each of a bucket you look where the data
you you draw some balls around them and
then you do this Sarah College which
curves out cups and that's roughly the
algorithm model many details and this is
white lie sorry but here are some of the
details
so the idea is that you know what
happens in the end is that there are
kind of this is why we call it to level
hashing is that there is the first level
is data independent and in some sense as
long as we are doing this data
independent think we cannot obtain
better row so we'll still obtain one
over C squared but but we hope is that
the first level will make pairs at
distance taozi so tau is some parameter
unlikely to collide which means that we
will effectively reduce to the situation
where in each bucket after this first
level will have both of small radius of
some kind of small radius and a level 2
once we have small radius we find min
you closing ball we can actually find
the balls of radius tau C divided by
root 2 and this is use this very nice
young theorem which says that diameter
tau is if there is a point set of
diameter tau C you can find minimum
closing ball of radius taozi by root 2
and and this is roughly half analysis
says and then it will be kind of two
parts right and greater part which loses
I mean basically doesn't have an
improvement on own robot improves on the
structure of a data and the second part
does the data row right and there are
some auditors in the algorithm that you
know we need to drop off some pairs that
are further than distance tau C because
they'll still be some efficiently you
know we'd like to find approximately
enclosing both just because this is
faster so you find bowls I mean what I
described to a spherical sorry colorless
age so one has to take this bowl you you
take some shelves where and approximate
them and run on each one separately but
this is this is the general kind of
overview and that's one relationship
just finals line just to repeat what I
say so what we are proposing here is a
new nearest neighbor search with which
obtains exponent role which is for nth
power query time obtains row which is
seven eighths by C squared for two and
seven-eighths by c4
on which I mean curiously goes below the
lower bound for that have been proven
previously for local SSD caching and and
that really the idea is to look at data
dependent space partitions right so
space partitions that do look at what
actual points we care about and of
course you know the natural questions
remaining are you know can we get better
upper bound for example you know first
natural idea is to think about
multi-level and this doesn't prove a bit
of a constant but definitely doesn't go
I mean all the way down but you know
might be considerate and natural barrier
which is half by chi squared this is
roughly because the mo 20 an hour
panigrahi proved lower bound of this
sort for for l2 and I mean that might
imply any receiver search lower bond we
don't know or maybe not I mean maybe one
can prove something like a data
dependent lower bound that would be
interesting possibility all right so you
look at it so you don't when you do this
phase partitioning you don't know the
query ok so this is video right so you
look at you look at your points you have
n points right you don't know where the
query comes in tow you have to partition
your space into some parts so that you
know comes your query and you have this
probably this p1 p2 and you know you
have this gap right this is what it
would mean so your function H kind of
will depend on the endpoints for which
you need to argue right right right yeah
but this is I mean okay so this is a
salt probe lower bound right and if the
problem there is mostly with the type of
lower bounds that you get is your query
time is something like Omega T all right
so you want you know just because the
estate of a lower bound z sub probes is
you know is around log n kind of threat
we don't have anymore especially any
higher lower bound for static data
structures suspect
and so you know proving a lower bound of
a sort of n to power something is still
far away for any problem right so there
is the question of Beijing good point I
guess you know it has to be with more
conditions in question that was the
problem changing the data is dynamically
changing if a set of points is dynamic
so this is for static data structure yes
we haven't thought about dynamic data
structures I mean original so that was
very very good part of your original
localization hatching but it was data
independent so in some sense it was very
good for dynamic data structures you
didn't need to restructure its face
partitions here it does depend so in
case you have stated the static data
structures it does give better
algorithms I don't know about whether
this can be done amazed at the moment
good question there are more questions
hey
well that computes the official program
for today and tomorrow let's see when we
start tomorrow when the first coke is at
nine tomorrow I'm here before them